KATIE MCLAUGHLIN:
What's wrong, Martin?
Having trouble choosing?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
I just can't decide
which tool I want to use.
I don't know if this new hammer
will do everything I need.
And I don't want to
throw away my old mallet
without being sure.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Well,
what if I told you
that you didn't have to choose
right now and you can use both?
MARTIN OMANDER:
That sounds great.
Stay tuned if you
want to know more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Liz
works for StoreCraft
as a site reliability engineer,
where she's on call maintaining
their custom storefront.
StoreCraft's systems are
developed in-house in Python
and have been running on virtual
machines for years, a set up
which evolved as
StoreCraft's businesses did.
These virtual machines use
slightly different versions
of Python.
This is causing extra pain
and work for Liz and her team.
Liz is looking for a
way to reduce this pain
by updating all the
components to current Python
and also migrating away
from virtual machines
onto something more
scalable, like serverless.
MARTIN OMANDER: Liz knows that
this upgrade will take time.
And her team needs to make
sure the existing system keeps
running.
She realizes that she
can best achieve this
by completing the
upgrade in two steps.
First, moving to serverless,
then making the language
upgrades.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: StoreCraft
is about to launch
a new recommendation
engine, which
is written using Python 3.9.
Liz sees this as the
perfect candidate
to deploy a serverless first,
skipping the virtual machine
altogether.
MARTIN OMANDER: Looking at the
options available on Google
Cloud, Liz sees that
while she could deploy
on Cloud Functions,
she would be forced
to use only specific
versions of Python.
However, she sees that
the newest serverless
offering from Google
Cloud, Cloud Run,
doesn't have this limitation.
So she chooses to
deploy there instead.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Creating
this service on Cloud Run,
Liz has complete control
over the container.
Making use of the official
Python images on Docker hub,
she can pick the exact
version of Python
she needs down to
the patch level
by specifying the base image
in the front line of the Docker
file.
As each Cloud Run service is
based on its own container
image, which are each defined
by their own Docker file,
Liz has complete control
over the languages
used in each part of her setup.
MARTIN OMANDER: Since
each Cloud Run service
has this level of isolation,
Liz can move each of them
to Cloud Run one at a time.
She is also able to maintain
the services running
on the original virtual
machines until the team has
the availability to upgrade.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: However,
during the refactor
of the account
services component,
StoreCraft's
development team finds
that it has a dependency on
the sweet-ldap package, which
doesn't yet support Python 3.
Liz is able to keep
the service running on
the now deprecated Python
2.7 by specifying the latest
version of Python 2.7
in the Docker file.
As soon as the sweet-ldap
package has Python 3 support,
Liz can test this new version
by gradually rolling out
a new revision of the service
using the traffic splitting
feature of Cloud Run.
She can set the new revision
of the count service
to, say, service
only 5% of visitors,
that way only some
of her customers
end up using the new code.
If she notices that something
isn't working as intended,
she can easily roll
back to the old version.
MARTIN OMANDER: By migrating
each service in turn,
Liz is able to control
them in isolation, allowing
for a more incremental
upgrade process and a more
reliable environment.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: But Martin,
I will have to take away
that mallet at some point.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK then.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: You
still can have your hammer.
MARTIN OMANDER: Well, I
do like this new hammer,
now that I'm used to it.
KATIE MCLAUGHLIN: Great.
[THUDDING]
Great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]